I'm sitting here in this mystical booth
to demonstrate the new Samsung gear VR a
virtual reality headset voila that
actually works off of Samsung's Galaxy
Note 4 tablet you just snap this bad boy
right in here and then look through this
viewfinder let me take off these sets
exchange them for these and you get a
full 360 degree with headphones you can
put on your fully immersed you can play
video games you can watch movies there's
a touchpad on the side of the device
that allows you to click on things
there's a volume control here also on
the side it's really quick pretty
extraordinary and it's been developed in
conjunction with oculus the makers of
oculus rift who have helped develop some
of the software here so i'm going to
watch pacific rim and you can imagine
that if you were sitting on an airplane
or something you might want to watch
this instead of looking at the smaller
screen it's kind of funny of course
Samsung was a pioneer with larger screen
devices but apparently even those aren't
big enough now you need an entire
immersive oh my god world there's a guy
right there there's a guy right there
it's pretty cool they haven't announced
pricing or availability yet um but I can
tell you it's actually pretty freaking
amazing